why is the border more overwhelmed under
your watch mr president because there
are three countries that are never had
there are fewer
fewer immigrants coming from central
america this is a totally different
circumstance
what's on my watch now is venezuela
cuba and nicaragua and the ability to
send them back to those states is not
rational
you could send them back and have them
we're working with mexico and other
countries to see if we can stop the flow
but that's the difference thank you
president
looks like he's sending
migrants to delaware give any comment a
response to that sir he should come
visit we have a beautiful shoreline you
should come visit delaware i like
delaware what's going on in delaware bye
everybody it's just not rational yes the
white house is not being rational right
now what does he mean it's not rational
to deport the migrants it is rational to
deport foreigners who are coming into
your country against the will of your
citizens and against the your nation's
laws it is very rational to deport them